How do you write clearly without losing
your authentic voice to AI? You know
that disappointing feeling when you
finish writing and you ask AI to clean
it up, but the text that it gives you
back sounds nothing like you? Well, your
readers notice and it destroys their
trust in you. My name is William. I'm an
English professor and I've coached
thousands of people to improve their
academic and professional writing
skills. And the nine techniques that I'm
going to show you in this video are
going to help you become a clear writer.
I just wish I'd learned these lessons
much sooner. And I'm going to break them
down into three groups. So, we've got
sentence level techniques, paragraph
level techniques, and idea level
techniques. Let's start with sentence
level techniques. Group one. If you want
your writing to be more clear, direct,
and concise, then the secret is
storytelling. When most people talk
about storytelling, they usually talk
about the macro level. They'll tell you
all about Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey, Dan Harmon's story circle, or
the butt sewed technique popularized by
the South Park guys. But what many
people don't realize is that
storytelling doesn't happen at that
grand scale. It happens at the level of
the sentence. Even in academic and
professional writing, every sentence
tells a story. So if you want to
communicate in such a way that your
story unfolds clearly in the mind of
your reader, then you need to forget
about those abstract patterns and focus
on what's happening concretely at the
sentence level. Let me show you what I
mean. So here's the same story told two
different ways. Which one is more clear,
direct, and concise? Once upon a time, a
climb up the Beantock was undertaken on
the part of Jack. when the giant's
discovery of him took place, resulting
in his fright. Compare that to once upon
a time Jack climbed up the beantock when
the giant discovered him and frightened
him. If the second one seems more clear
and direct, it's because it harnesses
the power of storytelling at the
sentence level. Every story is about
someone doing something, which is to say
it's about characters and actions. So
start by taking a look at what's going
on with the characters in these
sentences. And so the characters of
course are Jack and the giant. And those
characters should be center stage, but
in the first sentence they're buried
away in these prepositional phrases and
noun phrases. In the spotlight are these
actions climb and discovery. Now in the
second example, the focus is on the
characters. Now, that focus comes from
the subject position, which is the
grammatical location that gives your
readers that sense of focus. It's like
center stage in a musical or the middle
of a frame in a camera shot. It's what
receives the attention from the
audience, your readers. So, the first
writing technique is to put main
characters in the subject position. But
if you want to apply storytelling to
your non-fiction writing, then it's not
enough to just help your readers focus
on the characters. Every story is about
someone doing something. That is
characters and actions. Which is why I
always say to students in my
professional writing class that actions
are the most important part of the
story. It's what tells readers what's
going on. But many writers fail to pay
attention to the way that they portray
these actions. It's a little like
painting. Two different painters can
look at the same scene and portray it in
different ways. A realistic painter like
Rembrandt could look at a bowl of fruit
and paint every detail with precision
and clarity. But a painter like Picasso
could look at the same scene and
fragment it into abstract shapes and
planes. Both painters are looking at the
same scene, but they're constring it in
different ways. As a writer, the way you
choose to interpret and represent the
scene matters. So when you're thinking
about actions, you have to ask yourself,
how do I want to construe this action?
So let's go back to our example. The key
actions are climb, discovery, and
fright. But look at how they're
construed in the first example. These
actions are not expressed in verbs.
They're represented in nouns, right? A a
climb up the tree was undertaken. and
the giant's discovery of him took place.
And note what happens whenever we put
our actions into nouns. It forces us to
use these vague flabby verbs like
undertaken, right? Undertaken on the
part of Jack. The discovery took place
and that resulted in his fright. Now, by
contrast, in the second example, these
same actions are represented in verbs.
Jack climbed and the giant discovered
him and that frightened him. This is why
we're more likely to say that the second
example is clear because the main
actions are represented in verbs. So, it
tells us a clear story. We find the
someone in the subject position and the
something that they're doing in the verb
position. Now, in the last technique, I
told you to not use nouns to represent
actions. But, of course, writing is not
paint by numbers. It involves decisions
about when to use these tools and when
to avoid them. So the technical name for
that grammar form is nominalization.
Nominalization is when we construe an
action not as a verb but as a noun. And
they're sometimes called zombie nouns
for the way that they suck the life out
of the verb. So for example, the verb
investigate becomes the nominalization
investigation. The verb respond becomes
the noun response and the adjective
brave becomes bravery. These verbby
nouns are the main culprit of unclear
writing because they usually make the
writing feel more abstract, indirect,
and difficult to understand. But that
doesn't mean that you should never use
nominalizations. There are actually four
good uses of nominalizations. And one of
the things I'm always telling students
in my writing class is that languages
are organisms. They're always evolving.
They're always adapting. They're always
trying to become more efficient. And
just like any organism will not keep an
organ that doesn't serve some purpose.
The English language evolved to have
nominalizations. So we could do these
four things to promote clarity. And the
first is to use nominalizations in the
subject position to link back to
previous sentences. This is what creates
cohesive flow. So for example, if you
had this sentence, Watson and Crick
discovered the structure of DNA and you
wanted to link back to that sentence.
Well, you could capture the entire
meaning of this clause with this
nominalization,
their discovery. It's a noun in the
subject position that links back to the
sentence that came before. Second, use
nominalization to replace awkward noun
clauses like the fact that or the idea
that. So, for example, instead of saying
the fact that he solved the puzzle
surprised me. That's kind of something
we would say often in speaking, but in
writing, it's a lot of dead weight, the
fact that. So, if we wanted to get rid
of the fact that and we want to have uh
surprise me as the verb, then we can
replace this clause with a
nominalization.
His solution
to the puzzle surprised me. But
honestly, in this sentence, if what we
want is clarity, then we may as well
follow the principles from before with
characters in the subject position and
actions in the verb. So, we could just
as well say, "He [snorts]
surprised me
when
he solved
the puzzle,
and that works just as well." Third, you
can use nominalizations to turn clauses
into concrete objects. So, for example,
instead of saying, "I approved what he
proposed," you could just as well say,
"I approved his proposal." This is more
clear because the verb approved requires
an object, something to receive the
action. And his proposal feels more
concrete than an entire clause like what
he proposed. But here's the key.
Nominalizations work well as objects,
but not as subjects. So, compare these
two sentences. I approved his proposal.
That's pretty good. Proposal is the
object that's receiving the action of
the verb approve. But if you switch that
around, putting his proposal into the
subject position, something like his
proposal for funding arrived after the
after the deadline, well, that's awkward
because you've got proposal trying to
act like a character who's performing
the action of the verb. But proposals
don't really arrive. People do. So
instead, you could just write
he
proposed
after
the deadline,
proposed funding or something like that.
And the reason that works is that now
you have a concrete flesh and blood
character in the subject position,
somebody who can do the action of the
verb, which makes it more clear. Now,
fourth, you can use nominalizations when
you're writing about concepts that are
so familiar to your readers that they
basically function as characters. So,
for example, if you're writing to an
audience about climate science, a
sentence like the greenhouse effect was
a topic in recent conferences, that
works just fine. Now technically effect
and conferences are both nominalizations
but these words are so common especially
to readers who are interested in this
topic that you can disregard this rule
because for your particular readers
these concepts function like characters
in their mind. Now as you practice this
you'll need to distinguish between
nominalizations that express a common
idea and those which you can revise into
verbs. So for example in the sentence
there is a need for an examination of
the marketing strategy. This sentence
has three nominalizations
need examination and marketing. Now need
and examination would work better as
verbs because they name important
actions. So you would revise that to
something like need
examine. Then you would say who needs we
need. What do we need? We need to
examine. To examine what? To examine the
marketing
strategy. But notice that marketing
stays as a nominalization because it's
so familiar to your readers that it
works fine just as it is. So, the key
skill here is learning to spot which
nominalizations are hiding important
actions that should be verbs and which
ones are so familiar to your readers
that they already understand. Do you
ever feel like your writing is choppy,
disorganized, or just doesn't seem to
flow? If so, it's probably due to what I
call the Busousan taxi driver effect.
So, here in Busousan, South Korea's
second city, we have a lot to be
grateful for. Rolling mountains,
beautiful beaches, clear blue skies year
round. But if you ever visit, there's
something you need to be warned about.
The taxi drivers. The drivers here are
notorious for their driving style. They
don't drive smoothly. Instead, they
hammer the gas pedal on and off, on and
off. And they don't notice it up front,
but for us sitting in the back seat, we
had jerked around forwards and backwards
the whole way. It's enough to make you
seasick. And a lot of writing works the
same way. When you examine an individual
sentence, it's fine on its own, but over
the span of several sentences together,
they're choppy. They don't just seem to
work together. Start, stop, start, stop,
start, stop. And if that's how your
writing feels, then you need to learn
how to bring your sentences together and
give them a sense of flow. So, for
example, in this sentence, imagine that
you need to fill in the blank. Which one
of these sentences work better, number
one or number two? So the sentence says,
"Some promising results about viral
growth have been unlocked by venture
capitalists who harness network effects.
Number one or number two goes in here."
So many users concentrated into so
little an environment creates
exponential value. So the two options
are the concentration of active users
into a community perhaps no larger than
a college campus triggers a network
effect or network effects are triggered
by the concentration of active users
into a community perhaps no larger than
a college campus. Feel free to pause
here while you try to figure out which
one of these options works better. But
if you ask me, it's the second example
that works better. Here's why. The last
few words of the first sentence
introduce an important character network
effects with option one. The next
concepts that we hear about are the
concentration of active users which is
information that seems to come out of
nowhere. But with option two, the first
words of that sentence repeat what we
just heard at the end of the last one.
So those two sentences seem to connect
smoothly. Now, if you're a grammar nerd
like me, then you know that the
difference between these two sentences
is known as the active voice triggers
and the passive voice are triggered by.
And many writing guides will tell you to
avoid the passive voice. But notice what
the passive voice allows us to do. Not
only does the passive voice allow us to
line up the end of one sentence with the
beginning of another, but it also lines
up the end of this second sentence. Uh,
a college campus, right? Many many
people in a community no larger than a
co college campus. That sets up what
follows at the beginning of sentence
three. So many users concentrated into
so little an environment. That is all
made possible by the passive voice. So
the principle here to break the bus taxi
driver effect is to end sentences with
information that the next sentence can
pick up and continue. This creates a
handoff between your two sentences and
gives your readers that sense of flow
instead of choppiness. When readers
judge whether you're a clear writer,
they're actually evaluating two distinct
qualities. These two qualities work
together, but they're not the same
thing. You can think of your writing
like a jigsaw puzzle. One quality is
about the pieces fitting together
smoothly, but the second quality is
about those pieces creating a unified
picture on the box. Now, the technical
name for these are cohesion and
coherence. So, here's a passage that
flows smoothly. It doesn't have the bus
taxi driver effect, but there's
something wrong with it. So, it says,
"Soon, Portland will be the coffee
roasting hub of the nation. The aroma of
roasting beans fills the streets and
gleaming espresso machines line the
counters. The machines remind me of my
dad's old typewriter covered with keys I
would press randomly. His typewriter
always jammed on me. That's why I
avoided it. I prefer to write with a
blue pen on yellow legal pads. This
preference has been the topic of heated
debates between me and my creative
writing professor. In this passage, we
move from sentence to sentence easily
because the end of one sentence sets up
the beginning of the next one. But the
passage as a whole seems incoherent.
Why? Well, there are three problems. So
one, the subjects of the sentences are
entirely unrelated. We have Portland,
the aroma, the machines,
his typewriter. I avoided it. I prefer
this preference. All right. So if you
remove everything else and you just look
at those subjects, could you predict
what the passage is going to be about?
All right. Second, the sentences share
no common themes. A theme is a web of
closely related topics. And so a word
like coffee, you would expect certain
other words to appear like cup, drink,
uh conversation, date, that kind of
thing. You would not expect to see words
like preference, typewriter, in creative
writing professor. Not that they're
impossible, but they're just not part of
the same ecosystem of words. And third,
there's no thesis to unify the passage.
And so, how do you fix this in your own
writing? Well, the thing is, you can't
really predict how readers are going to
judge the flow of your writing just by
reading it yourself. It's because you
know your writing too well. So, you need
a system or a diagnostic process, I
find, to analyze it more objectively. So
imagine if you had written the following
and now you want to make it more clear
for your readers. What could you do?
Well, the passage says, "A clear visual
hierarchy at the top of web pages helps
visitors identify what a site is
primarily for. A sense of usability
emerges when a series of menu items
reflects a limited set of core
functions. But the purpose of each page
is obscured by apparently arbitrary
changes of navigation. confusing
websites result when that happens. It's
unclear, isn't it? That was hard to
listen to, hard to read. But if you had
written it, you would bring all of your
prior knowledge and experience to
bearing onto your interpretation of the
sentence. In other words, you might not
see what readers find and what you just
experienced reading it. So, how would
you go about catching that? How would
you make it more clear? Well, here are
three steps that you can follow. The
first thing you want to do is underline
the first seven or eight words of every
sentence and stop whenever you hit a
verb. So that would be clear visual
hierarchy at the top of web pages. A
sense of usability
but the purpose of each page
confusing websites result. The second
step is to just ask yourself, do the
underlined words constitute a relatively
small set of topics that name related
ideas? Now, here's the thing. Even if
you see how they're related, will your
readers see how they're related? And do
these underlined words name the most
important characters whether they're
real or abstract? So, in this case, we
have underlined clear visual hierarchy
at the top of web pages. a sense of
usability, the purpose of each page, and
confusing websites. The writer of this
passage might argue that yes, they're
closely related, but as readers, I think
we'll all agree that it's hard to see
how these concepts relate to each other.
And so, in that case, if you discover
that in your own writing, then the third
step is to rewrite. In most of your
sentences, use subjects to name the
topics of that sentence. and put those
subjects close to the beginning of the
sentence. In which case, you would get
something closer to this. Visitors
identify what a site is primarily for
when they see clear visual hierarchy at
the top of web pages, especially in the
main headings. They feel a a site is
usable when they encounter a series of
menu items that reflects a limited set
of core functions. But when navigation
seems to change arbitrarily, visitors
lose track of each page's purpose. When
that happens, they feel they are using a
website that is confusing or even poorly
designed. So you see now the beginnings
of these sentences name a few concrete
characters that are the most important
characters in this story. Having
consistent topics at the start of your
sentences helps your readers understand
what the passage is about globally. This
creates coherence. Random topic shifts
creates lost context and
disorganization. If you want to
articulate your ideas with not only
clarity, but also strength, then there's
a valuable piece of real estate in your
sentence that you don't want to miss.
Now, in the last lesson, we looked at
creating coherence and cohesion by the
way that you start your sentences. But
the way that you end your sentences
determines how readers judge both its
clarity and its strength. That's because
when readers build up momentum in the
first 9 or 10 words of a sentence, they
can get through complicated material
more easily. The key is that readers
want complexity at the end of the
sentence, not at the beginning. So, the
way that we move readers through your
sentence, it's kind of like a plane
lifting off in flight. The plane needs a
clear, smooth runway at the beginning to
build up speed. And once it has
momentum, it can handle the complexity
of lifting off and climbing through
turbulence. But if you throw obstacles
on the runway at the start, the plane
never gets off the ground. So, it's the
same thing with sentences. If you start
with complexity, they never gain the
momentum that they need. But if you give
them a smooth start, then they can
handle complexity at the end. So for
example, compare these two versions of
the same sentence. Statistical and
demographic examination of public school
enrollment and funding patterns over the
past five decades to identify trends in
educational inequality is the focus of
this research. By contrast, you could
write it as, "In this research, we
examine public school enrollment and
funding patterns over the past five
decades using statistical and
demographic methods to identify trends
in educational inequality. Obviously,
version two works much better." But it's
interesting to notice why that is. See,
in version one, we struggle to
understand technical terms immediately.
We have statistical and demographic
examination, public school enrollment
and funding patterns over the past five
decades, trends in educational
inequality. It's a struggle to
understand these technical terms
immediately while simultaneously hacking
through a 22word
subject.
Look at that. In version two, we have to
manage only five words before we've
already pushed through the subject and
the verb. And it's 12 more words before
we even encounter what could be
considered a technical word that might
slow us down. And by that point, we have
strong enough momentum to carry us
through the complexity at the end of the
sentence. So the principle here is to
locate two kinds of complexity at the
end of the sentence. Long and complex
phrases and clauses and new information,
in particular, unfamiliar technical
terms. All of this belongs at the end of
the sentence. Your sentences should
begin with a short introductory phrase
or clause followed by a short concrete
subject followed by a verb that
expresses a specific action. And why am
I saying that? Why should your sentences
begin this way? It's not my personal
tastes. This is the way that readers
read. The reason that you found this
sentence easier to read and this one
harder is exactly because of this
principle. After the verb, the sentence
can go on for several lines if it's well
constructed. So the general principle
here is to organize the information in
your sentence from simple to complex and
from old and familiar to new. When you
do that, when you consistently write
sentences whose subjects name a few
central characters and join them
together with strong verbs, you're
likely to get the rest of your sentence
right. In the process, you'll create a
passage that is both cohesive and
coherent. But all these writing
techniques might be putting the cart
before the horse. Because clear
sentences and smooth paragraphs aren't
really worth anything if you can't
convince your reader that the passage is
worth their attention. Readers don't
really read non-fiction for
entertainment. To be honest, it takes
work no matter how clear a writer you
are. For readers to put in that work,
they need to see the value being
exchanged. So the challenge here is how
do you present your ideas so that
readers not only understand them but
also see their value. Well, the key here
is to imagine your non-fiction reader
like a shopper at a market with stalls
everywhere. So then imagine that a
vendor turns to the shopper and says,
"Yes, ma'am. Step right up. You too can
be the proud owner of this brand new
thingamajig. Nobody has ever made this
thing before and I put a lot of work
into it." So, it can be yours for the
low low price of $9.99. The shopper
probably isn't going to buy this widget.
Why? Because the vendor said only that
it's new and that he put a lot of work
into it. But that's not valuable to
consumers. Consumers don't buy things
just because the manufacturer put a lot
of work into them. And they don't buy
things just because they're new. They
buy things when they perceive value and
value is a solution to a problem. So
just as there are different kinds of
consumers, there are different kinds of
non-fiction readers. Some readers know
very well what their problem is and
they're searching for a solution. Others
are already aware of a solution and
they're trying to find somebody who can
deliver it. Others don't even know that
there's a problem. And depending on what
kind of a reader you're addressing,
you'll have to adapt your message to
meet their level of awareness. In the
world of non-fiction writing, the
problem matters more than the idea. So,
here's the key principle. If readers
cannot perceive a problem, they cannot
perceive value. Now, when we're deeply
interested in a topic, we'll probably
read anything that we can get our hands
on. But we read even more attentively
when we read about a problem that's
important to us. Now, that problem might
be finding a good job or understanding
the origins of life. When we're
motivated to read attentively, we read
with greater understanding. What we read
seems more clearly written because we're
so intently engaged. All of this happens
in your introduction. So the first job
of your introduction is to establish a
problem that readers care about. And
here's my framework for setting up
problems. So you can imagine the
solution to be like your idea, your
thesis, the one idea that you want
readers to walk away with. And for the
sake of this abstract demonstration,
let's call that idea X. So the first
thing you want to do in building your
introduction and setting up the problem
is come back up here to open with what
we call the status quo. The status quo
means the way that things are right now.
And a really good way to set up the
status quo is just to take the opposite
of your idea. So if your idea is what
might it be um
online education is better than offline
education, right? That's your thesis. So
then you would just want to set up the
status quo to be the opposite of your
thesis. So you would say some people
some people think offline education is
better than online education. This is
abstract. Of course you're going to
write it a little bit more eloquently
than this. But these are the major moves
that you want to make here. You want to
open with the exact opposite of your
thesis. So you're basically saying
here's the way that things are. The next
move that you want to make is a
concession. Why do you do a concession?
A concession shows some understanding
and appreciation for the way that things
are because you're about to dismantle
this. You're about to throw this away
and replace that idea with your idea.
So, you don't just want to come off the
top ropes swinging saying this idea is
trash. Everybody who thinks it is
stupid, right? You want to show some
appreciation for that idea. So you can
do that by saying well of course this
idea you know has led to this positive
benefit or it's not all wrong or you can
understand why some people believe not X
because then the next move that you make
is the destabilizing condition. You're
going to use one of these big power
words here like but or however. And that
word is a big signal to your reader that
something is wrong with the status quo.
This is a really important part because
you're now like now you're making your
reader alert. Now they're like, "Oh
yeah, this is what I believe and okay, I
like this person. He understands what I
think and he appreciates it." And now
you're saying, "But if you think that,
then there is something wrong here."
Okay? And then the next step is here's
the cost. Here's what bad consequence
will happen if we don't fix that
problem. Or conversely, you could say
here's the benefit that you will that
that will be conferred upon you if you
do solve that problem. And ide of course
you want to position these things
according to your specific reader,
right? What cost are they afraid of
paying or what benefit do they want to
gain? And so finally, once you've set up
this problem and the stakes, now the
reader is ready to receive your idea.
It's not just an idea, it is the
solution to a problem that they care
about. So from the moment you begin to
plan your writing project, you don't
just want to imagine that your task is
writing about a topic or passing on
information that happens to interest
you. This is honestly one of the worst
pieces of writing advice that you hear
out there when writers say, you know,
just write for yourself. No, write for
readers. Okay? So, instead, see yourself
as posing a problem that your readers
want to see solved. All right? So, we've
already established that introductions
need to motivate readers with a problem
and to frame your document or your text
with key points or ideas. But once
you've got your readers in the door, how
do you keep them moving through your
sentences and paragraphs? You need to
help them see the big picture. So
imagine that you're giving somebody
highly detailed directions to your
house. You could jump straight into the
minutia. You could say something like,
"Turn left at the third stop sign. Go
past the blue mailbox. Take the second
right after the gas station." But it
would be far more helpful to give them a
major conceptual overview first. You'd
say something like, "All right, so
you're heading northeast toward the
river district and then cutting through
downtown to the residential area on the
hill." And then once they have that
framework, all the individual turns and
landmarks will make a lot more sense.
And it's the same thing with writing.
Give readers the conceptual map before
the detailed terrain. Now, I guess this
depends on your reader because when
readers are deeply interested in a
subject, they'll struggle through
clotted sentences if they have to.
That's why even bad writers get read if
they can motivate their readers. But
incoherence defeats everybody at some
point. If your readers can't follow a
line of thought, they're likely to give
up. Now, when we're teaching coherence,
it's kind of funny because it's not
something you can underline or see on
the page. It's not about the individual
sentences being clear. Coherence is an
experience that readers create as they
make sense of what they read. It's the
abstract shape that emerges in their
mind as they decode all your sentences
and paragraphs. And this is where the
curse of knowledge really becomes a
problem. Now, as the writer, you already
understand your material quite deeply
and you bring to the text all the
background knowledge. So, your document
feels coherent to you. You can connect
the dots because you already know how
everything fits together. But of course,
your readers do not have that knowledge.
And without that knowledge, they depend
entirely on the signals and clues that
you give them on the page that helps
them follow your thinking. So to grasp
the coherence of a major unit of
writing, readers need to see these four
signals of coherence. So the first thing
your readers need to see are clear
section boundaries. Like here and here
is how I've represented them. Readers
need to know where one section stops and
the next one begins. And you'll use
headings to identify the start of new
sections. And ideally, what you want to
do is use key concepts in those
headings. So, for example, if if you're
using a certain web of related words
here, uh a moment ago, we talked about
online education. So if this section was
about the technology stack that you use
in your online education platform. So
for example that could be Zoom and a
microphone and certain other uh
technical utilities that you use in
order to set up your online classroom.
Well those words are going to appear
throughout this section. And so don't
put some unrelated concept here. And
definitely don't put like uh kind of
abstract riddle or you know kind of
inside joke that you'll only understand
when you read it because these section
headings set the context for
interpretation. So it needs to make
sense not later but here. So in other
words, when you're making your section
headings, choose important concepts that
will recur throughout the section and
build it out of those terms. So after
introducing key terms in the section
heading, what you want is a short
introductory segment. That could be an
opening sentence or a short paragraph,
something that introduces readers to the
central idea that will be developed
throughout this section. Now, the third
thing readers want to see in order to
perceive coherence are point sentences
at the end of an introduction. So, if
you imagine this section right here to
be the introductory paragraph following
the model that I just showed you, right,
where you have your uh solution down
here, well, they're expecting to find
the point of this entire uh essay to be
at the end of the beginning, if that
makes sense. It'll it'll occur at the
end of your introductory segment. And
that point, you could call it a thesis.
It's something that captures the central
idea that you're trying to develop
throughout the piece. When readers can
see that point sentence at the end of a
short, easily grasped opening segment,
they read and understand what follows
more easily. And the fourth thing that
helps coherence are repeated key
concepts. So toward the end of the point
sentence, readers must see words that
express the concepts that you'll develop
in the rest of the unit. So once again,
imagining that this is our introduction
and at the end of this introduction, we
have our point sentence or thesis. Well,
in this point sentence, use
several of the key concepts that will
occur throughout the piece. readers use
those repeated concepts to organize
their understanding of the whole. And so
bringing these four principles of
coherence together, the idea here is to
begin each major unit, that is each
section and each subsection with a
short, easy to grasp segment that states
the point and introduces what follows.
Then the part that follows is longer and
more complex. It's where you expand on
and develop or explain what you've just
stated. You help your readers by
building these signals into your writing
deliberately. Now, there's a basic
principle of clarity that applies
everywhere. Individual sentences,
paragraphs, sections, subsections, and
whole documents. Once you understand
this principle, you can apply it at
every level of your writing. Think of
every unit of your writing as having two
parts. So part one is the index which is
a short easily grasped opening that
states the point and introduces key
concepts. Part two is the discussion.
That's the longer more complex part
where you develop those points and
concepts. This structure works like a
table of contents for each major unit.
The index tells readers what's coming
up. The discussion delivers on that
promise. So, let me show you how this
works at four different levels of your
writing. Level one is simple sentences.
So, for example, imagine the sentence
opposition in Seattle to its designation
as a testing zone has been intense.
Compare that with Seattle has intensely
opposed its designation as a testing
zone. The second sentence is more clear
because the subject and the verb form an
easy to grasp segment that introduces
the main idea. Level two, complex
sentences. So, compare these. Deeper
insight into coral reef ecosystems and
the effect of ocean acidification
destroying marine habitats by weakening
calcium carbonate structures has led to
a scientific re-evaluation of industrial
fishing practices. By contrast, you have
scientists are re-evaluating industrial
fishing practices worldwide because they
have deeper insight into coral reef
ecosystems and how ocean acidification
destroys marine habitats by weakening
calcium carbonate structures. In the
first example, the point is buried here
at the end. In the second, the point
occurs right at the beginning and all
the details that follow and develop that
point follow at the end. The claim is
introduced at the beginning of the
sentence and it is supported by the
longer and more complex clause that
follows. Level three paragraphs. Here's
a paragraph without a clear opening. 25
high school students solved math
problems that were checked to see how
well six weeks of training helped them
use algebra in everyday situations. That
skill is an important part of using math
in real life. In problems solved before
the training began, the students failed
almost completely to use algebra in
everyday situations. In problems solved
after 3 weeks of training, the students
clearly tried to use algebra in everyday
situations, but did so inconsistently.
In two more problem sets, they use
algebra in everyday situations more
consistently, but never reached the
expected level. In a final set of
problems solved four months after
training ended, they did no better than
they did in the first problem set. Their
training had some effect on their
problem solving during instruction, but
it was inconsistent. And four months
after training, it had no measurable
effect. Now, I don't know about you, but
that was pretty difficult to read.
There's no clearly distinguished opening
unit, and it doesn't announce its key
themes. So, here's the same paragraph
written with a clear opening unit. In
this study, 25 high school students were
taught to use algebra in everyday
situations. They did so successfully
during training, but the effect was
inconsistent and less than expected, and
four months after training ended, they
had it had no the training had no
measurable effect. Notice how the
clearly marked opening unit states the
main point and announces the key themes
that will be developed. Now level four
is taking this same concept of an index
and a discussion and applying it to
sections, subsections and entire
documents. Now that short, easy to grasp
opening unit could be just a paragraph
but in longer sections it'll be
proportionally longer. But even so, at
its end, it expresses the point of the
unit and introduces the key concepts
that follow. Now, of course, holes are
made out of parts and parts make up
holes. So, you can take this pattern and
apply it to any level of your writing.
Be it a subsection, a section, a
chapter, a book, whatever you want. It
should all follow this same basic
fractal structure where you have the
index section at the beginning. It's a
short, easy to understand section that
introduces the main points and the key
concepts that will follow and then a
discussion and then we wrap up that
discussion with the point of it all and
a conclusion kind of leading into the
next point. And if we break that down,
this discussion is going to be made up
of maybe one, two, three parts in this
in the context of a section. These parts
could be main ideas. This could be just
a single paragraph. Expand it out. If
you're looking at a chapter, then these
could be different sections. This could
be the opening section of that chapter.
And of course, it follows with a book as
well. Now, each of these parts is going
to have their own index and discussion.
So, as you see, it's a fractal pattern.
This pattern of the index and the
discussion should recur at every level
of resolution in your writing. Simple
sentences get a short subject and a
longer predicate. Complex sentences get
a short main clause plus a longer
supporting clause. Paragraphs get short
introductory sentences plus longer
development. Sections get short opening
paragraphs plus longer discussion. And
whole documents get a short introduction
plus a longer body. Master this one
principle and your writing becomes clear
at every scale. But you can't just learn
clear writing in theory. You need to see
it in action. So, watch this video next
where I'll show you how a Pulitzer
Prizewinning novelist used these exact
principles to transform dry academic
research into a blockbuster Harvard
Business Review essay that's still one
of the most widely read and shared
articles two decades later. So, be sure
to go check it out.